par là les premiers je voudrais en fait
lancé un point d'appel en s'il vous
plaît dehors peut-être remonter l'info
comme quoi ne plus utiliser les autistes
comme insultes cela restera le moment
fort du grand débat en bourgogne
le président de la république qui
échangent avec un millier de jeunes à
étang sur arroux un exercice original
sur la forme à l'image de ces deux mois
d'une consultation à l'ampleur inédite
il y aura eu tout d'abord les mairies
habiter à recueillir les doléances dans
ce que l'on appellera des cahiers
citoyens si l'on additionne les chiffres
de la saône et loire de la nièvre et de
la côte d'or sept cent trente quatre
communes ont joué le jeu
sur ces 7 134 cahier ouvert 570
contiennent des contributions autrement
dit un tiers d'entre eux sont restés
vides
autre possibilité de s'exprimer les
réunions d'initiative locale à
l'initiative de mr d'associations mais
aussi de simples citoyens
elles se sont déroulées parfois dans des
lieux inhabituels comme ici dans ce bar
elles auront plus ou moins satisfait les
participants je sais pas comment on peut
faire puisque là c'est assez des failles
à les propos assez durs empreints sens
que ça va être compliqué mais
mais bon moi j'espère qu'on va y arriver
c'est pour ça que je veux participer au
débat et puis j'ai des choses à dire
j'ai une chose à proposer
moi je vais m'en aller parce que si les
gens commencent à se fiche sur la sur la
figure par rapport à déchaîner des
sujets bateau mais moi ce qui
m'intéresse ce sont des sujets concrets
et malheureusement il n'y a pas de
réponse
en tout 230 de ces réunions se sont
tenues dans les trois départements
enfin des stands du grand débat auront
même été installés dans des lieux
publics fortement fréquentés comme la
posta nevers où la gare de dijon